[Music]
in dumb criminal news
my favorite me too submitted by hipster
weed Oh that hipster weed though that's
that good stuff right hipster we don't
think I'm I talk a lot of [ __ ] about
hipsters but I gotta say they do have
good taste in a lot of things so you're
hating yes
okay a drunk man okay a drunk man stole
a cop's breathalyzer and sped off with
it to avoid getting arrested mm-hmm well
I don't know if it works like that I
think he's gonna get arrested even
harder yeah if you speed up you're
running from the cops they usually want
to arrest you that much in this case he
kind of got away with it he did because
as far as what they're reporting she
hasn't gotten caught oh [ __ ] yeah so
dude he's really good at getting away
then this takes place in India and New
Delhi Oh see that changes everything
cuz cops can't run really fast in
sandals I told slippers get caught in
like chain-link fences and yeah I'm
kidding this is a terrible joke what
anyway oh hey if this was a Chinese copy
would have been worse lucky is that a
Chinese or Korean copy no because when I
thought this whole situation was going
down I imagined like a drunk guy in a
sports car in America and he stole it
and he [ __ ] drove off as soon as it
was India I pictured a very busy road
like and then he's on a scooter and he's
laughing like ha ha and he's like and
he's weaving in and out and it's like oh
man we lost them I did not picture that
at all I pictured a very open road in a
village and this guy was running away
and this was his dog like running on oh
yeah he goes ah he's being too hot he
just chills out he's like so it was like
a fat cop and everything those skinny
ones a mustache and you just you just
understand that it's too hot in India
he's not gonna go yeah always look good
bro that amazing facial hair that
connects yeah it looks really good on
them good for you guys
so any picture on the video goatee
mustache yes oh yeah
but like a mustache it's a very it's a
very specific particular person that
camera or man that can rock a mustache
any of us rocket I don't think so
Joe looks good oh yes a goatee though
that's a mustache are you talking about
mustache only only when's the last time
you went a facial hairless
I don't know it just likes it cuz she
goes you look like a man so I was like
I'll keep it how do you girl hair in the
middle well he tried I don't know if you
could give you a tutorial bro my dad has
a fool he has the full thing jealous and
then so me and my brother got the short
thing I can get any I guess my mom
doesn't have a few here and then I'm
like 40 here now it used to be 18 now
it's like 40 yeah Koreans don't look
good it depends you get you know those
old fashioned Korean people like back in
the day where they go that long
there's some hairy ass Korean people
dude so women like that some women do I
personally don't I gotta shave my beard
off like every single day like you could
see it right here his five oclock
shadows all this squinting I don't like
it cuz I'm on your kids like my chin
[ __ ] hurts it's like stop yeah we do
all that I don't like people with beards
eating like watching them eat Oh cuz
they get stuffed sauces on there there's
eat all over their face and then I think
continue to eat gets greasy ER and
greasy ER and greasy ER and it's mixed
you yesterday's food I'm pretty sure the
shower but but it's a weird because like
they're like oh no it's like it's clean
it's like yeah it's clean cuz you got
that gunk out but I could spit lisi it
get greasy err continue mine will just
look like long nutsack hairs that are
going all over have you tried no just
trying it you mean the whiskers do I
look like a catfish what the whiskers
going this way I try growing is I just
look homeless man so this guy here a
constable constable after he noticed
that this man named Rishi was driving
very drunk when he pulled him over he
had him he had him breathe into the
breathalyzer and then that's when he
told him to park on the side or side of
the road and then he quickly reached out
grabbed the device and then drove off
but the cop was able to see the last
four digits of his car registration
numbers so they went to his house but
this man had already left for London for
a professional tour oh they don't report
that they caught him damn man I was
hoping it was like a donkey or something
yeah but then he did have in contact
with the police and he said that he
threw the device a week what's a
professional tour what kind of what is
that but if he's a good tour guide Oh
you could be a tour guide it's true I
feel like if I was in another country I
would take my chances of evading the
police as an American what country
though because you don't know their laws
and some of their laws are scary I'm
more scared to be caught by the police
by these cars I mean oh they can mess
you up yeah yeah he co yeah scary did
you see that news spread I think it was
vogue they'd have a better vogue India
recently yeah it was pretty [ __ ] dope
well let's double back I think it's
because I'm so used to seeing like
Bollywood films where the Indian women
that are portrayed they're all super
light-skinned yeah and the vogue India
they weren't you don't mean so it was
like I think a lot of cultures always
have like a lot of Asian cultures they
push the light-skinned people a lot
could make the more fair-skinned stuff
but go Guinea didn't have that so I
thought its kind of course oh I don't
know what but for all of us always that
that light-skinned thing yeah why is
that they should push more of the round
butt thing that's in right now dude
yeah that's the thing I like that I do
too
I'm with you buddy skin doesn't matter I
love it no I watch I don't even need to
see the face is just good but you know
the POV yeah if it's just the butt and
then I pretend that that's me yeah oh my
god that's me you can only watch all
about POV I don't like POV why show me
an angle that I can't see that's why POV
is because you pretend it's you oh I
know what you're saying yeah like the
one that's under the [ __ ] yeah
explain yourself what are you reading
okay I get the POV part I love it I can
see that when I have sex I can see that
in real life
like you can see those angles I know no
no no no you know why that's not natural
my friend that's why I want to say that
natural angles my friend it's like this
I understand what you say I understand
what you're saying
yeah like some genetic stuff like it
because it's almost like you're there's
yeah interactive yeah it's in my mind
and then you don't have to see the other
guy because it's you [ __ ] that girl
this thing is this it's kind of like
people who like to [ __ ] in front of a
mirror yeah I mean yeah when you're
[ __ ] somebody you just see that
person there but when you [ __ ] front
of a mirror you get to see the angle yes
the whole thing that way yeah okay I
also like sideways but the you know what
I'm saying
no yeah and where the camera is like
from the ceiling down no I'm like doing
that real life I don't like watching
that type of porn but like personally I
like doing that because it takes less
energy yeah cuz you're cool chilling on
the side you could see I could see my
girls hands shoulders shoulders yeah and
you just [ __ ] it rubbing her shoulder in
circular motions of course when you're
missionary and you're like it's a
workout man yeah you're like putting in
work and when you're a doggie you're
like putting in work but when you're on
the side you could take a breather but
you're still doing the app or you could
just lay down and just fall asleep and
have her do all the work you could do
that too not every girl's favorite
midnight knocks out when the guy knocks
guys she just has to use it it wouldn't
mean what do you mean Oh
wait missing something just tell me
about it like because I want to try my
girl people don't agree with me Bhama
pitch you an idea okay so imagine that
there's a really good movie named one of
your favorite movies I like there will
be blood okay imagine there will be
blood right but let's say in that movie
there's like a romantic scene and a love
scene imagine a romantic yeah and then
but then instead of them fading to black
or cutting away it's a full-on sex scene
so you get a good story and you get good
[ __ ] I mean I would love to see that
people don't agree with me but you can
you could do that with a lot of French
films oh yeah
hey shell penetration movie there was
there was a there was a film on Netflix
that had something color blue warmest to
call it which was our low it's called um
because I was watching like a bunch of
indie flix and then there was something
that was grated like [ __ ] yeah I don't
read subtitles think it's nine songs
that's what it's called like nine songs
I was watching it and I kind of just
moved past it and as I got this is
[ __ ] boring and then my friend ray
comes out he goes this is a film that's
very known because of this like crazy
Nuria so I went back to it and I started
watching it again and they have an
actual [ __ ] in there and the dude
[ __ ] nuts on her face you can see
it's dead yeah no I'm talking about like
Wonder Woman
can you imagine Wonder Woman like before
she goes to battle [ __ ] lesbian fetus
a new one who is an actress that new one
god the banging dude [ __ ] Iron Man
Iron Man banging [ __ ] electronic dick
comes out and then like
a real person under that he has sex and
[ __ ] and then you might see that in like
the the--everything yeah you're right
they separate that don't they they said
no but I don't I don't know then one you
know sometimes they fade to black and a
baby comes out of nowhere cuz they had
they may love well like they take
[ __ ] kiss and then it goes away
it's like show me the passion this is
the passion right here this is a lot of
passion flow right there dude it looks
like it's a spider on your back imagine
like you you watch you watch action
movies right yeah and they're fighting
you give us an example let's say you
watched Jackie Chan or Creed - Creed -
yeah creature right like there's
fighting but imagine when it's fighting
now it's just a cuts - right it's the
same thing as this like ding-ding fade
to black and then it comes back I'm not
trying to get a boner while I'm watching
Iron Man though you know what I mean
exactly I see your point now but what if
okay
I'll add something to Joe's story
because in a movie you want to get all
experiences right yeah cuz you have a
Wonder Woman but it's a Marvel superhero
Aquaman's coming out then you have the
sex scene iv sexy Jason Momoa wanna see
that [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of some chick
right then you also go to this scene
where they're dining where he's having
lunch with one of his buddies and in the
middle of the theater they bring out the
actual food they're all eating so not
everyone it gets to eat whatever they're
eating there you get to have the full
ball experience and you all get to eat
that cheese you know what it sounds like
both of you actually don't like film
that's what it sounds not love them you
don't because you cannot watch a film
while you're eating a full meal
nope I'm trying to be in the story he
to be more integrated with what the
experi hate going to I pick because
people are eating [ __ ] food you
cannot eat food and then watch a [ __ ]
film it's not possible that's not the
point is it the eating part of it now
the point isn't the eating part so for
example imagine like we [ __ ] or what
so what's what's what's the movie okay
like imagine we're watching and glorious
bastards right before you go and
everyone gets to wear one of the
bastards uniform I would hate it so it's
not even part of the food but you're
sitting there you're like oh I'm in this
movie like a soldier's uniform people do
that for the Rocky Horror Picture no I
mean they dress up to watch it that much
in the world more
[Music]